hello welcome to a gang swap plays
doubleheader I'm dying to wire joined by
the only other person in this office who
can speak to soccer games football games
mr. Eric Taylor I don't know Danny yep
back again was here one year ago yep
rare FIFA every air dive into the
marketing department to get your assets
and we could've got on my calendar 20 16
sep tember I'll be back again maybe
that'll be the year that the pro I've is
better than FIFA maybe it's happened
already knows that when this airs FIFA
score will or will not be up yet let's I
don't know let's see okay see right now
you have to go to gamespot.com to see it
so it is a double header because we're
gonna do pro have now 15 minutes is also
there's gonna be a gamestop place for
FIFA 16 s you can go check that out as
well but here we are on the home screen
of pro volution soccer at 2016 which is
a game that has got nine at a ten on
gamespot people are very excited about
it and I play every Pro review every
year last year's one was pretty solid as
well based on this engine this template
but this one certainly I guess sort of
reaching parody with a lot of the
mechanical stuff on game are on FIFA but
then I think on top of that I'm evolving
a lot of interesting ways let's just get
all that I guess the you know mode stuff
added away yeah early right senior
exhibition match of course the online
stuff very popular in the the online pro
evolution community which is still
incredibly strong the Champions League
license of course sits with Konami and
they've also got to cover Libertadores
the Europa League and a couple of other
ones now you can make your own leagues
and cups of course then they have the my
club stuff which is I i prefer the m why
was with me with the ultimate theme
masterly and math stuff but yeah this is
kind of their ultimate team i guess and
the my club stuff feasible more the
master league of course is in there as
well and then a couple of extra bits
above in fact the UI for this kind of
reminds me of last year's 34 days yeah
they seem to be getting a little bit
more closely aligned yeah which is not a
bad idea because fifa is you know for
the last 16 70 years in the dominant
yeah they've been great game so yeah but
the most important thing of course is
the on pitch action so what I'm gonna do
is play half of a game against the AI
and then we'll get you in for the second
sure right so obviously as well the one
thing you'll notice is that the licenses
don't exist unfortunately Arsenal my
team is way way what's the owner team
with the
oh it's also happens to be the guys you
support right how far a coincidence God
they've got a couple of other ones
obviously like they don't have the same
problem with the earthy vitiates there
and they have a bunch of Spanish teams
better other European team yeah it's
weird actually cuz i got this pu league
which has got some interesting ones
other european teams I didn't know this
I know practically there's a Belgian
team that's got a native already we knew
Bayern Munich of course olympiakos yeah
so like extra little bits and bobs and
they have a bunch of the Spanish team
scores Barcelona that is like everyone's
basically into a guitar you know madigan
everything so how about we lure I don't
know what do you think we'll do a I'll
put your knife on the other side so you
can play that jumping on the second half
yeah I'll be let's see I'll be a Bray on
the droid 4 for y not as much as I love
the Gunners I don't want to be no North
London of course you know you can update
that stuff and you can change the names
as lots of websites and faq is out there
for you to check out and how to do so
let's stick it up to so amateur begin
arrange your regular professional top
player player Oh superstar is like
legendary I guess yeah let's do it on
pro and see I feel like the AI in this
game isn't smashing so maybe we'll stick
it on top player all that apologies if I
don't score because I've been playing a
lot of feet found my pilots a little bit
messed up as a couple of real stadiums
in here a couple of fake ones as well
and some zeros in your I believe old
trafford as well so let's just do that
for them or they sing like it yes I'm
gonna do five minutes against the AI and
five minutes against you your beautiful
set I wish I had an English accent
because in Rita and I could like
commentate you know who are the big
commentators they say the EPL games well
what's interesting at this one is
they've got Jim Begg lane' who went to
the same school as me in waterford a
knowledge and a peter jewelry as well so
it's kind of like the itv crowd i think
so you wouldn't necessarily hear this
stuff to north america but they're
familiar voices to me same school John
O'Shea went to as well yeah you memmio
me about some six years ahead of me I
think yeah and presentations pretty good
this is the Fox engine it's running in
the automations really good and the
detail in the faces is
hey I think it's better than X guys
dimaria hahaha it's crazy eyes and yeah
they've I feel like the presentations
pretty solid overall is rooney with his
new hair for the sake of fake hair okay
for the sake of time I'm going to pass
on watching Real Madrid alright and try
and get to grips with this again so pro
evolution and I'm surprised at how much
it reminds me of thief I feel like
everything down to like the camera
angles as as a more of I guess they are
so different right I mean you could feel
the difference between them yeah the
sort of the really like lame blankest
difference that I used to always say was
the Pro Evolution it was harder to get
in front of the goal but once you did
you had a higher chance of scoring
whereas in FIFA get in front of the goal
getting in a shot taking position wasn't
that difficult but you generally had to
like kind of work a little bit harder to
get the finishing finish that sort of
highlight will ascribe it to my friends
who aren't familiar with PE s as PE s
was in the in the back you know back in
the day when it was winning eleven was
more so oh [ __ ] purists or fifa was more
arcadey yeah but I think recently FIFA's
done much better and become a more
purist than me oh and they're already
I've conceded a goal see the problem is
I've come from spying I've spent quite a
lot of time playing fifa 10 teams you
definitely need to be a little bit more
cautious with your play and so one of
the sort of gripes I have maybe we
didn't see here because I was definitely
my fault and is that the AI in this
seems a little bit overly aggressive
I'll say to the point where they make
silly decisions in the back and also
their strikers are hungry in a way that
like it's almost like they're playing
five-a-side I've been chased down like
you get chased down with the ball
basically everywhere on this page which
seems so they're they're constantly like
pressing yeah watch it watch it so look
got the ball Miller fields like all
right it's fair enough all right
passable okay yeah yeah like I'm gonna
go over here give me a bit of time to
think about it like no we got this guy
coming in i'm gonna have to so it's kind
of yeah they pressed you they don't play
any zone like they don't kind of play
I maintain you know and just keep keep
the ball in front of them strategy it's
they press you like Barcelona yeah I'm
what and so this is the weird thing is
is that I'm I guess I've it's a case of
like getting used to to what game you're
playing but here and I mean I want to
scratch oh damn it come on Gareth Bale
you would have expected the Welshman I
know it i told her than everyone else on
the pitch I don't know and but what it's
basically doing is is encouraging you to
be super pass heavy so there's a lot of
ticket akka and much less so than FIFA
you have you can like pass the ball
around like no one's business in the
game what's the what's the air so when
you're doing moves you know how the
arrow shows up around the player yeah
this little dude I think that's for
manual here let me let me just say is
that for manual skills and I've had a
little bit of trouble sort of getting
the player movement stuff to work which
is why I've not really delving into that
guy but when I'm tapping around like it
just everything always goes to feet so
which is fine but it's just I guess it
would have this level as well but it
just encourages it sort of encouraged
you to play a different style of soccer
field i'm gonna put this over and over
the top try que paso ah that was good
for great ball have you taken a look in
the settings see cuz i know and fifa you
can do autosys passing then you can go
yeah if you go manual it's really hard
right yeah maybe it's the same which is
what I tend to do it ran the sort of
post christmas time of these games is to
really crank up at the difficulty of it
and that's so that's kind of the thing
right I bet I bet all these games about
private FIFA is that so much of this
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
some people like there's a reason why
PES fans are super inter pares a reason
why fee for fans of super into to FIFA
and it's because like these games are
different in terms of like inches and
not miles and those inches make the type
of experience you're playing and I think
more crucially challenging yourself to
play the other one is more difficult
because of that so what I think is
interesting about this year's pro app is
that I don't necessarily think it's
wonderfully brilliant but what I feel is
that it does enough similar to FIFA to
encourage people to go over while still
retaining its own sense of identity so I
think that's why it's gotten like a lot
of critics excited about it because it's
not just this weird
weird music where do I like a a kind of
hyper it's realistic in some ways and
very Arkady in terms of like you know
everything else in terms of the pace of
the game in terms of the passing like I
feel like it's it's kind of doing enough
to allow you to get here we go oh wow
who knew he had all right but I also
love the cometary I think it's super
solid and for me saying that like it's
the type of game where you get in the
box you'll score and then I haven't
scored in three times come here in the
boxes puffy wait we had the same problem
last week we did this is this is this is
the way of demoing games on on on a live
streams around gameplay clubs so the
thing is we're both pro headphones like
we both play with pro of controls in
FIFA were both like we winning eleven
for you and like the heyday of like pro
air like 450 oh god I'm like quality
games but there's no denying that FIFA
has really been dominant and not because
of the licenses like they always used to
lean on they've just made some really
really quality and yeah so what is it
that like I'm really enjoying this when
I played them both every year but this
one to me is like it's the closest I've
gotten to wanting to swap over but i'm
not really sure if it's if it's gotten
me to swap yes there you go nanalo your
car Bella couldn't he's gonna do is
trade my celebration yes did you see odo
odo Beckman junior on New York Giants
wide receiver did that what a touchdown
and did that are you kidding me hate
paid homage to Ronaldo yeah did you have
this boom branded on there when he did
it no probably not so sorry to that
point like what would it take for you to
try and spare over or for you to give it
a go like is there something about this
series has that's making you feel a bit
more interested the one thing that would
would make me go as if my friends
started playing it well no and that's
that's what it comes down to at the end
of the day is I get most of my enjoyment
from people playing online with friends
and all of my friends play fifa so I'm
not going to switch at least in terms of
playing online I could maybe switch and
play single player you know do they have
the license of a Champions League which
is
FIFA lacks that so that's what I think
would interest me but until my friends
switch and I think that's which thing
for most people you're gonna stick with
the game that your friends on right same
with consoles right you're gonna get a
ps4 and xbox one yeah I know what your
friends have so it's tricky you know
like habit is a really difficult thing
to break out of yeah I think that's what
a lot of like especially with games like
this where the difference is so granular
like that's where the sort of the devil
is in the detail with and and this is
definitely like I don't think I'm I
think like finding the right difficulty
is like crucial to this as well because
I've certainly had games in this where
it's been just way too easy like the
opening game I play like completely
trenched Barcelona which should never
happen my groove 51 or something I
scored a goal i put it up on my youtube
channel i scored a goal like a screamer
from outside the box on the volley like
it was just yet sighs and boss the more
you play and i think this is very much
in our fifa review as well the more you
play these games the more you find your
like the difficulty level that sort of
speaks to you in a little bit you know
yeah yeah if you're coming from only
ever playing people into winning eleven
you probably won't like it yeah you
might say it's too easy it might say
it's too hard like something it it's
very much a case of that yeah at the
banya yeah i'm fining you hug now giving
it a bit of time I know I guess yeah it
says I guess thing perfect alright you
be United of course and this is the
other aspect is that like some people
play the AI some people play online with
their buddies some people only play
local to player like I've I think most
of the time if I was go back and like
think of mine you know time would you
know probe forward stuff it was probably
playing my mates like ninety percent of
the time and now I'm freaked out by the
concept of you you've never played this
pass right there no but well I played it
briefly last year with you right but are
you making the mistake of thinking are
200 there we go this will see a free
kick come on Wayne Rooney are you
controlling to keep it right now no I'm
controlling this wall of gentleman
holding their gentleman's areas
oh that was that's pretty solid Rooney
it's close you almost scored a free-kick
with him in the game assateague oh yeah
and I keep thinking I'm gonna blow it
over because in FIFA when you go full
power yeah it goes out of the stadium
but in this it all depends on where
you're aiming the the accuracy meter and
then you can go to school powers in one
and it seems to not really expect where
at least at this level like it's
probably different if you're playing a
stump or something yeah yeah now I'm
less interested in talking about the
pros and cons of this game and more
interested in beating you in this video
those demos for both these games as well
I believe I know there's definitely a
demo probe and I would encourage anyone
who's a fan of the series or not to give
it a go because oh oh yeah you certainly
have nothing to lose right it's free
demo yeah and it's it's it's worth like
challenging yourself to play a different
type of game and it's I think it's
exciting for footy fans to have sugar
house it had to have an option again I
think I think it's it would be terrible
if Konami had decided to stop making
these games as well because obviously
that sort of Baghdad of triple-a
development of this in terms of metal
gear solid and you know they're gonna
start making mobile games around
everything else and pastels well for
them it sells well in Japan it sells
well in Europe hanlon Europe which is
why they lean so heavily into her
division yeah and you know La Liga and
the Chinese league stuff so and we just
really wrote something on gamespot about
the Konami coming on saying that they
expected to be competing directly or
passing fever in the next year or two so
they seem to be quite confident in the
changes they're making and I think um
like last year's game was very much like
I enjoyed last year's game because it
felt different to a bunch of probes that
came before and as somebody in the games
press I think change is always something
that's interesting to me and oh here we
go oh no the Great God the great ah
she's getting new goalie no I'm saying
hey he is not a real starting keeper
it's not there the other Spaniard I know
is where is he an in both the moment cuz
he's not playing for either these hey
Ronaldo we're not celebrating against
his
squad woody he wouldn't hug other people
either he'd soak it all up himself yeah
of course of course that Cathy ass so
let's see that again josh is a good this
is a good one time Bali and that's good
as the one scores that's on YouTube but
I'll take it my favorite thing as well
as you always remember you're playing a
pro I've game when you hit star sh and
it automatically gives you a replay yeah
no matter what it's like that room that
just reminds me of that of being in like
University someone those hey days all
right 21 I believe in you are I'm I
don't know if I believe in myself I'm
gonna feel way better when we give up
when we get fifa go oh but oh no oh no
God there we go here we go I'm having a
great time with pro I don't know what
you're saying BAM Oh Gareth with your
stupid ponytail see how do you a finesse
in this game cuz I remember I asked
asked you last week if you figured out
how two min SEO this man give me suck a
lot it's one of these things where it's
not oh no what's going on we could see
this is just an O another let off for
the the beekeeper and Victor what's
going on and yeah it's one of these it's
like if you asked me how where the
letter T is on a keyboard I just need to
like cuz like you would do it right now
yeah well like the Run button is
different as well so I'm just a cup so
this is just a few things that yeah I
haven't quite got used to that I'm sort
of defaulting to based on my experience
with people but for the most part you
you are right there identical in terms
of control yeah run bucking slightly
different there's a new button fee for
this year which basically gives you like
a crazy drilled ball which is oh here we
go ah almost yeah like what is your
opinion of how a place like what oh
Jesus Christ no way I don't believe it
oh my god I give me forgive me all right
i'm gonna skip this I'll need see hey
look at this Ronaldo scores against his
own Club the Maria he's gonna love it
just shows you the transient nature of
the football across the world
alright so you have to skip this point
well I got to get it onto if you want no
I want to put that to my facebook
profile every yeah how is it feeling to
you as somebody who you know like a lot
of people on gangs by where our old pro
I fancy but sort of stuck with you for
the past couple you definitely feel
different than it has in the past it
feels more similar to what I'm used to
in terms of fifa's controls which I like
because I enjoy Peters controls again it
just it depends on one of my friends
going I don't see them switching over so
at the end of the day I'm probably gonna
end up getting fifa again oh but it's
good to see that they're making strides
in changing the mechanics yeah and I
think a lot of it depends as well on
like it's really crazy i remember
talking to the folks at County about
this and at e3 how like certain people
and this happens actually across the
board with sports games happens in
racing games a lot and where certain
people love certain modes and they'll
actually only play that mode like for me
I actually play exhibition games a lot
like I usually a career mode London and
for the games I don't really have the
time to you anymore so now I kind of
just hop in hop out yeah very much so
and well I'll hop in and I'll end up
playing for like two hours I would like
that's good that's for whatever reason
that's what I do so like for some people
Master League it's just it's master
league or nothing she's on people it's
it's doing needing the real licenses
because all they do is the premier
league so I feel like a lot of us like
people are so specific about how they
play that was a good show how they play
their the football games just you don't
tend to have that many like you'll have
fans of specifically the series that
don't really change bringing the thing
that seems to always grab people in
peace was the ultimate team you know
that you have to thing that people will
crazy over right which is probably why
the whole you know my club stuff isn't
yes and you as well okay here we go we
got we got ten minutes left I feel
like you know we're gonna do this again
with oh here we go hit it you bum whoa
I've had times where I football's over
the top and they've like frustratingly
gone for a header when they really
should have just waited for it to drop
down so that I've had like sort of it'll
a I quibbles with this pro a balsa and
I've also added with the goalkeepers for
something like I you know I feel like
like it was always the case you could
kind of score a little bit easier in
program but like I feel like this year
the goalies can't do some real dumb
stuff sometimes and the defenders as
well because they're so eager to get the
ball with you oh my god oh that finesse
was beautiful that deserve that deserve
to go look at something well what
happened Ramos super jinking run no
Rooney can move like this anymore whoo
yeah back in the day when he was looking
up grannies on the internet ah that's
fry young man go go go get rid of it
when watching this here we go here we go
this is it last minute last minute
winner the old wonder through ball here
we go here we go come on the lens yet
Ronaldo has it against so-called ticks
on the inside shoots oh great commentary
as well Peter Georgia get me too but hey
what was it now oh actually and i will
say that bizarrely and somewhat like
okay not the case here but I've had some
referees who have been really weird
about not calling fouls the most obvious
holding a horrific and they just don't
which especially in European football i
find to be quite unrealistic because you
know that's you know you're being refs
tend to be a bit more sensitive like
yeah I think that's probably again them
trying to speak to the pace of pro
evolution soccer and it's definitely a
faster more you know less there's less
time to sit back and relax in this
definitely you compare it to earth other
foot sock games oh god Jacques going
last minute are you oh no the pie come
on no oh I will put in the corn and play
it out
is that it almost I'm gonna go down for
a draw re boom up the pitch larath
Butler rip it up when does Lara Lara pit
at heart okay oh my got a breakaway here
no that's it all right Ranma jitsu
monday nighta to pro evolution soccer
2016 9 out of 10 the reviews up on
gamespot and if you like this one and
make sure you use tell us in the
comments what you think of this year's
pro f and of course make sure you check
the other gamespot plays out fifa 16
which will be up right now on gamespot
on youtube at the same time thank you
right Thank You Danny thank you for not
letting me win a smashing that son of a
[ __ ] we'll see you guys on the next
video and for all updates on FIFA and
pro evolution as stay tuned to gamespot
com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you